do you think japan sinks is his worst
work that you've seen so far then
out of like the three i've seen yeah
it's probably i mean i haven't
seen everything masakiosa has to offer
yeah i've seen a lot but i i'd probably
say it's
yeah it's probably his weakness yeah i
think definitely for me it was his
weakest and
it literally just removed the cult yeah
that's good
so many problems would be solved if he
just had yeah i i
would say no not every problem would be
solved but a lot of it
it would be like a lot better because i
still had problems with how the
characters were written
and how the story played out but
removing removing the middle arc
would have made it like an easy seven to
eight out of ten yeah
um because there was still like i said
there were still some amazing scenes and
that was
some planning amazing and it was like
peak you are certain if i was actually
invested
i i would think that this show had some
pretty amazing moments in it
um because i feel like just you got
bogged down by its story so much
yeah um whereas his other works i feel
it was it was like a nice combination
between this you asked the style of
directing because
he has a i don't know some of his scenes
the way the way he
the way he portrays and directs
especially like the emotional scenes
they just
they they can hit really hard and i
don't know what he does she's so close
shut the [ __ ] up i said it in my head
like it hits thesaurus
yeah well i i agree i i i definitely
think that you also
regardless of how strange it is that the
way that he portrays
you know character designs and just
movement in general just animation
just animating okay i'm i'm one of those
anime viewers who does not care who the
director is or any of that stuff i
just watch the show and that's how i
watch your anime i do that with
everything so
i mean i could tell it was from the same
guy who did devilman within like 10
seconds yeah yeah
yeah that's how i do because yuasa's
films and series have this really weird
thing where
sometimes you look at a character design
the ugliest oh wow
that looks pretty cool and then the next
scene it looks like it's written by like
the intern you know
it changes i think there was like a few
frames in it where it was like
characters talking and it was like bro
like pain
you could take a screenshot of that and
just be a pokemon
you i will say out of like all his works
i feel like japan syncs was his most
like
normal looking work in terms of visual
style
no no no no you like you compare ping
pong the animation
and then you go to devilman crybaby and
then japan sinks
i i would i would say he's progressively
gotten
in terms of his big series yeah more
like
more like normal ping pong is one ugly
luck in show but in
a great way in a great way like he had a
very unique art style and
some of the scenes were like they had a
very unique animation style and some
i would still say sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't work so well
um but it was definitely a very yuasa
style i mean at least you know it's him
yeah yeah how many [ __ ] of those
generic isekai shows are you like i
are these all animated by the same
[ __ ] people they all look the same
like i can't tell you ask any soccer
guitar and they'll probably know it's
like
this was directed
protagonist now and it's literally a
carbon copy of kirito
yeah i i remember doing like a copy and
paste of
seven different like isekai protagonists
and they all looked
exactly the same it was all that
generous probably because they're all a1
i think it's the exact same art style
the exact same animation all the time
and it's like it's such a breath of
fresh air
you can get anything different oh no
that's what i love about masaku because
he's just
so weird that it's just instantly
recognizable especially you know
japan sinks as you were saying even
though it looks the most normal probably
to
the general anime viewing audience they
would look at those characters and be
like oh that looks [ __ ] weird
but then you go back to massachusetts
catalog you watch something like kaiba
yeah like that thing that doesn't even
look like anime yeah yeah that thing
looks like uh
you know some kind of like disney demo
that it was locked away in the disney
vault for a while
that's about jojo as well they're like
yeah the art style's weird i can't get
into it i'm like you'll know
you'll appreciate
i was going to say i completely forgot
about the one shot and you're also
getting one show when we're talking
masakusa um tatami galaxy oh
no tommy galaxy was [ __ ] like you
watched yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] amazing it's monogatari but on
crap it is
like this this this will test your
reading ability to the max
if the monologue is so fast that
japanese people struggle to keep up with
it
what the [ __ ] do you just like go back
yeah it's
i've never heard of monologue and just
talking scenes that go by so god damn
quickly yeah
it is it is monogatari on crack
essentially it's it's it's basically
like if you take monogatari but try to
speed run the dialogue
and that's that's an episode of the
tatami galaxy but it's [ __ ] great
yeah that and that's on top of the
[ __ ] crazy moth like you was a visual
yeah we're just like i don't know if
this is like a dreamscape
or if it's just weird yeah yeah but it's
great it's fantastic